proposition  european next generation eu by standing  united  27 member states backing the commission  we raise money on the capital market to  fight the  worst economic crisis ever  together in next generation eu  we now have a unique recovery tool with  750 billion euro  of course 27 countries agreeing  something  on this scale and of this  unique nature is a challenge  but today we have an agreement that next  generation you will have  390 billion grants  topped by 360 billion in loans  and because this is a european  investment  in our european union it is essential  that the european parliament plays a key  role we now have a massive  and unprecedented financial firepower  1.8 trillion these are small  league videos  long live europe vive